homeless destitute and traumatized these
are just some of Indonesia's tsunami
evacuation a few days ago everything
they had worked so hard for was swept
away in a few terrifying moments a wall
of water so powerful so unrelenting it
simply couldn't be stopped Linda has
lost everything but without a shred of
self pity Linda tells me homes can be
rebuilt but loved ones cannot be
replaced tsunami tsunami so I grabbed my
kids and ran as I saw the water rushing
towards me if we hadn't seen the wave
we'd be dead if we've been sleeping we'd
have been killed because there was no
sign of a tsunami at all no earthquake
in a receding water no wind if we hadn't
have seen the wave that would have been
it for us I thank God that I'm alive
even though I lost almost everything my
family is still together and our lives
are the most important thing it is this
remarkable resilience that lets
Indonesians carry on from one day to the
next one disaster
[Music]
and being a nation so calamity thrown
Indonesia has learned to respond quickly
food and water shelter and medicine but
even the most efficient disaster
management cannot diminish an uncertain
future these people are now preparing to
spend their fourth night away from their
homes many have lost everything and
obviously there's nowhere else for them
to go but some do have homes to return
to but they're too afraid to go back
they're waiting for their government to
tell them it's safe the man who leads
Indonesia's response to natural
disasters told me this an Army had
presented new challenges and anak
Krakatau a--
the volcano that triggered the giant
deadly wave could still unleash more
carnage is it safe for Indonesians to go
back to the coastline now not yet so
this way we have encouraged people to
stay away from the coast this is what we
are going let see in a couple of these
we are still doing the assessment of the
damage and loss and we are also learning
about the possibility for the relocation
for the people so for now there is no
end in sight to the uncertainty tomorrow
next week or into the future being born
inside the Ring of Fire means for this
generation of Indonesians this disaster
may not be their lives
ahsha's Joshi Sky News